قرر قاضي التحقيق بالقطب القضائي لمكافحه
الارهاب بتونس العاصمه الابقاء على رئيس
حركه النهضه ورئيس البرلمان المنحنى راشد
الغنوشي في حاله سراح بعد جلسه استماع
ثانيه دامت 12 ساعه فيما يعرف بقضيه
التسفير الى بؤر التوتر وقال الغنوشي بعد
خروجه من الجلسه من القضاه قرروا اطلاق
سراححه بعد ان تبين لهم ان القضيه مزيفه
والهدف منها اقصاء طرف سياسيا على حد
تعبير
ست قضايا الان رفعت بدنا وكلها لم تصمد
امام النقد امام
التمحيص لم تصمد ولم يجد القضاه بدن من ان
يطلق سراحنا رمانا الملفات لم تغلق بعد
ولذلك ينبغي ان يضل حريرين ولا نتوهم بان
الملف الاستقلال قضاء قد حسنا نهائيا ولكن
حقق خطوات المهم نحن نستبشر بمستقبل تونس
المؤامره الحقيقيه اليوم مش همم
التسفير لانه يعني حتى على الاخر احنا
والحقيقه قضيه وهميه هذه قضيه التفسير
التفسير لانه الذين نحن ضد العنف